Hey everybody, how's it going? My name is Mayuko
and welcome back to my channel where we talk about
tech career and life. So today, again, we're going to
talk about salary negotiations. So i posted a video
recently about Whether to Negotiate your Salary
and so today we're going gonna follow up and talk
about how to exactly do that. And this is from my
conversation that i had with Sarah, who is the Lead
Negotiator at levels.fyi. She was on Muko's Corner,
my show about leading a life that feels more
you in both your life and tech career. Sarah, again,
just has like, so much great information from her
time as a tech recruiter at Amazon, Facebook,
and Google to talk about the do's and don'ts
about how to negotiate a salary. So the topics
covered today will be like: how do you answer what
are your salary expectations, and exactly what
medium is best for having these conversations.
And before we get started, i wanted to say thank
you to the sponsor of today's video, Skillshare. As
we're kind of in the mood to like, learn new skills
like how to negotiate your salary, Skillshare is
an incredible platform to learn a lot of great
things. It's an online learning community for
creative and curious people where millions come
together to take the next step in their creative
journey. Skillshare is curated specifically for
learning, meaning there's no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and follow wherever your creativity
takes you. And it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual premium subscription. While we're
kind of on the topic of money, i found a really
great course for how to build good money habits
Justin Bridges, who's a fashion photographer and
former finance pro, made this course Modern Money
Habits: Five Steps to Build the Life You Want.
The course includes gaining insight about your
current spending habits and then also identifying
small changes that prevent debt and then creating
a realistic plan for retirement. And of course
because i know you all are tech people, or curious
about tech, they have tons of great classes about
coding as well. So check out Skillshare and the
first 1000 of my subscribers to click the link in
the description will get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your creativity.
Thanks again to Skillshare and now let's dive in.
Mayuko: Okay next i want to talk more about how
do you actually negotiate. Specifically, i have a
lot of questions about this, but i guess like the
first question that i had... i think this was one of
the questions that i really was curious about when we
first started talking was: when a recruiter asks
you what are your salary expectations, what's
the best way, what's the golden answer,
the do's and don'ts of how to respond to thatquestion?
Sarah: Don't give them that number. Don't give
them that range, because like i said, the range
is really large. You don't know where you land in
that compensation band and so i would recommend
push back on that recruiter and ask:
and you don't have to answer anything
either. If you don't know the answer, just let them
know,
And then, you know,
usually recruiters are pretty respectful of that.
Another thing too is, if you're in the state of
Washington or California as the candidate, when you
request for a compensation band, legally speaking
they have to share the minimum wage with you
And recently with Denver too, they passed a law where
for any employer, when they post a job description,
they have to mention like, the minimum salary range
too. So the recruiter can push for it, the recruiter
can ask, there isn't anything in place that, you
know, tells them that they can't ask, but as the
candidate you're not obligated to answer that question.
Mayuko: that's reallygood to know.
I think in the past, i recommended
to you, all my viewers, that you should say "i expect
to be compensated competitively" which is fine, but
i think, instead, flipping the question to them, because as soon as you put out a number out
there, you basically might already be giving
yourself away at a discount, which is great
for the company, because then they're like "wow we
get someone at this caliber for this cheap, great!
let's just like keep going with their number!"
when in fact, you're actually worth a lot more.
Sarah: Exactly, and it's just like, you know, once you
give a number, the recruiter will hold you to it
So if you say 230k in total compensation, they will
give you exactly that, like, nothing more, nothing
less. And let's say you start interviewing
with another company, and they give you 300k.
You can't come back and be like, "well just kidding,
like, now i want 300k". You know, now the recruiter
can say, "wow he came back, you know, and tell me the
other competing offer, which means that he really
he or she really wants this position. I'm not gonna
move the needle, and they will eventually cave and
it's the best offer. You know, if i'm a really
aggressive recruiter, they'll do that. And then
another thing too, when they give you the range,
don't say yes, don't say no. Let's say you flip itback on them and say
and let's say the recruiter tells you, "All
right well the range is 100k-120k, how does
that sound to you? Do you like this number? Avoid saying, "yeah no that sounds great" or
"no that's really low" Keep things a little bit more
open-ended by saying, "that's a really good start"
So that yeah, you open that door to yourself to negotiate later.
Mayuko: For sure, yeah, it's like you leave it as
lukewarm as possible, for as long as possible iswhat i'm hearing.
Sarah: Exactly. With negotiation, you
want to be... you want to use really neutral verbage here. You don't want to under
share, but you don't want to over share at thesame time.
Mayuko: So then at what point do you actually
give a number, or like who's the... who should be
the first one to give a number then, i guess?
Sarah: So even at the very end when the recruiter, you
know, shares with you the good news like, "all right
the team really loves you, they thought you do
really well in (ABCD), they see a lot of growth potential
in you," you know, "we're ready to move on to the
offer stage, what are you looking for?" Even at
that stage, i still would recommend: don't give your
number. You want to take this call
to really understand their compensation philosophy.
They can't just be pushing for a number when
when they don't tell you
what goes into it, right? You can't make a decision
without being informed, so push it back on them
and say: "truthfully, you know, i've been really busy
prepping for the interview, i haven't put much
thought into it. If you don't mind...
Youknow, once they go over everything again,
you can just push it back on them one more time
saying, "you know, this is a little bit newer for me
and everyone has a different compensation structure,
i know i'm not comparing apples to apples. If you
don't mind just sharing the numbers with me first,
it would be super productive or effective or super
helpful for me, i would greatly appreciate it."
Mayuko: it's almost like a game of poker. I'm just like,
waiting for them to fold, just like waiting
and waiting and waiting waiting, and then having
them be the first to show their hand.
Sarah: Exactly, andlike once the recruiter has to explain everything
for you, they'll just like be i might as well
just share a number now.
Mayuko: Right, and like you mentioned, at that stage, you've already gone through the entire interview
process, you got a sense for the company culture,
you got a sense of what they're looking for in
this role, you have their compensation philosophy
together. You can piece all of those together, even,
that when they give you a number, you have the data
and information to be able to confidently say
"Actually, based on what i know and what i've
learned, i think i'm this much instead."
Sarah: Exactly, and
you want to do a lot of the asking good questions
during that call. Like asking about the bonus
structure: how does that work typically, when
is the payout, is it once a year, is it twice a year,
is there any other bonuses on top of, you
know, what you guys offer, and things like
that. And for companies that don't offer a bonus,
that's the perfect window for you to use that
as leverage against them like, "hey since you
don't offer me any bonuses, what i want to be mindful
of is inflation, and you know living costs are
just keep going up. So essentially if i don't
take this into consideration now, the longer i
stay with the company, essentially the less my
take-home pay is going to be, and i don't want to
be in a position where salary is a thing for me to
have to leave the company, so i hope you understand
where i'm coming from." They can't say no to that
you're going to be the biggest [jerk] if you
say no after that request, right?
Mayuko: that's true!
Use all of that knowledge you learned in
AP Econ to talk about inflation, to talk about
money, and use all of that to your advantage. This
whole conversation of this back and forth between
yourself and a recruiter, recruiter has a hiring
manager and other folks behind them to
make decisions about all of this, but what's the
best format to be having this conversation?
Sarah: Good question. So typically what i would recommendis to
do that over via email. After the
recruiter tells you, we would love to move forward,
they go over the compensation structure with you,
perks and benefits, let them know "this is a lot of good
information, let me just take some time to process
all of this and get back to you later. Would
that make sense for you/would that work for you?"
As a recruiter, for myself, it's so much easier
to, you know, kind of follow the thought process
because sometimes it's really hard to like, maybe
when i'm on the phone, someone just pinged me, i
got distracted, maybe they were asking me 140 but
i misheard them and i wrote down 104, for example.
So just to have everything on paper is
so much easier for the recruiter to you know
not make any like, mistakes when it comes to numbers
there. And let's say if i have to get an approval
from their manager, it's so much easier for me to
just kind of forward that email to the manager
or the compensation team. So as a candidate, you
have so much more control over your narrative
because you could be saying the perfect thing, but
communication goes both ways. It's also dependent
on what/how the other side is perceiving that message.
So if this person misunderstood what you were
saying, and this person is relaying all this
information to the team, you don't know what ran
what went wrong in that process, like things can go
sideways really fast. Or maybe this recruiter just
explained something completely off and the
manager, she could take it the wrong way
and that's kind of what could potentially
jeopardize your relationship with the manager.
It makes life so much easier on you to do it over
via email, because a lot of the time too, i i would
see this happen with my friends where they, you
know, i'll prep them like "ask for this much" and
they were like "yep nope i got it" and then we would
rehearse it and then when they're on the phone
they get so nervous that they start to like
discount themselves like "well, i guess like i mean
i kind of want 300k, but like i would be okay with
250" and i'm just like "oh no" i'm just like "oh whattt"
The best analogy to think of this too
is when you send the recruiter an email,
and then you have a call with them after. It's just
the analogy of like when you watch a movie, and you
reading the book before the movie is so much easier
to understand, right? Versus if you just watch the
movie and you've never read
the book before, you have no idea what's going on
in the movie. So that's like kind of taking the
call without priming the recruiter, like what
you're going to talk about, and you have to explain
everything live, they're just going to sit there
and be like okay like "i guess it makes sense but
i'm not sure" So email is the best way to go:
easier for you to lay out your thought process
there,  much easier for the recruiter to share all
that information with the team. You have so much
more control over your narrative.
Mayuko: Thank you all
so much for watching the video i really hope you
liked it. Make sure to check out the other video i
did about salary negotiations featuring sarah, and
if you'd like to just watch the recording of the
live stream i did on Muko's Corner, then you can
become a member today by clicking the join button
down below and get access to the full recording.
My members help make Muko's corner a reality and
also supports me in my channel, and allows me to
do what i do. And if you haven't already, the other
way you can support me is by clicking subscribe. So
take care and i'll see you in the next video byeeeee